experts estimate that over 2 million  Star Wars fans ended up watching their  very first football game last night  that's true yes now as a result a lot of  the Star Wars fans that watch last night  now will love football as much as Star  Wars in fact here's some footage from a  pickup game at a local park earlier  today they're really getting into it  there they are they formed a circular  field out of traffic cones not very  official  there's obi-wan leading the huddle  they're playing with a basketball that's  not right now wanna be modal notes has  it a lotta action on the field  now they have a football but they've  left it the original packaging so it  won't decrease in value now Princess  Leia has possession chased by Boba Fett  okay I'm not sure what that was  there's Yoda breaking through the pack  and maskless c-3po is just watching the  trailer again there's Darth Maul again  showing off his feet  I guess that's technically a touchdown  [Applause]